let's talk about something huge that
changed the arab world
they call it the arab spring protests
that began
10 years ago in tunisia spread across
the region
almost 30 years of mubarak's regime
ended
and started wars years of war have
devastated syria
libya has been in turmoil for nearly a
decade
tunisia though managed to avoid all that
tunisia is often referred to as a
success story out of all of the arab
spring countries
but can we really call tunisia a success
what did tunisia do that other countries
didn't
and is the arab spring over
it probably makes sense that on the 10th
anniversary of the arab spring we look
at how an
act of extreme desperation started it
all
it happened in tunisia in december 2010
mohammed wazizi sold fruit in the street
he was 26 years old supporting his whole
family
and making hardly any money one day the
police tried to confiscate his cart
they said he didn't have a permit but
buazizi said the officers wanted a bribe
a policewoman even slapped him and when
he tried to complain to local officials
he was ignored so outside a government
building
he set himself on
muhammad died a few weeks later
within weeks there were protests across
tunisia
muhammad's plight resonated with so many
people
because they were also suffering from
some of the same frustrations
the most powerful man in the country
brought down
by one of the most powerless
people across the middle east and north
africa felt inspired to demand change in
their countries too
[Applause]
it does not seem that they are going to
be easily satisfied
unless the president himself stands down
they were calling on these governments
to be held accountable for the social
injustices that they were subjected to
for decades
it was a revolutionary moment on a scale
that we hadn't really seen
since the struggles for independence
from colonial rule
so here's a quick recap of what happened
where in tunisia the president was in
power for 23 years
but he was kicked out after just a month
of protests
over in egypt it took just 18 days to
get rid of hosni mubarak after 30 years
egypt then got its first democratically
elected president mohammed morsi
but his government was overthrown by the
military and the military is still
pretty much in charge
in libya muammar gaddafi was captured
and killed after 42 years in power
that created a power vacuum and led to a
civil war that's still going on
yemen's president ali abdullah saleh was
pushed out after
33 years but since then the country has
been more divided than ever
and fighting between the rebel houthis
and a saudi-led military coalition
has created one of the world's worst
humanitarian disasters
and then there's syria it's sort of the
exception because bashar al-assad hasn't
gone away
what started as peaceful protests there
became one of the worst conflicts of our
time
with assad's government groups including
isil and foreign powers
all fighting for control other countries
had uprisings too
like bahrain
[Applause]
but saudi arabia sent troops across the
border to save the monarchy
so in most countries the arab spring
didn't lead to what many protesters
wanted
some would even say things went
backwards we've seen
renewed authoritarianism and a level of
oppression that
is you know even worse than it was from
before the arab spring and in some of
those cases
but let's look at one country that
appears to have got some things right
as a young democracy tunisia has a lot
going for it
it got a new constitution it's held
several elections
the media are considered free and people
can protest too
tunisia was able to undergo a relatively
peaceful political transition
the nobel peace prize for 2015
is to be awarded to the tunisian
national dialogue quartet tunisia has
also done something
remarkable i'm talking about the truth
and dignity commission
it was set up to investigate things like
rights abuses and corruption under the
former regime
there were more than 62 000 complaints
from victims
some of the hearings were even televised
it seeks
accountability in some cases it seeks
reparations
it seeks national reconciliation so it's
an
inherently controversial and political
process because it really digs deep into
the roots
of the ugliness of authoritarian rule
and oppression
little wonder then that there's been
resistance politicians from the old
regime
are back in power and they're accused of
trying to stop the commission's work
they even passed a law that grants
amnesty to officials accused of
corruption during ben ali's time
there have also been security problems
fighters have been crossing over from
libya and civilians have been attacked
this mediterranean resort was full when
a gunman
started shooting the economy has
struggled too
international lenders like the imf
offered bailouts
but the spending cuts they demanded were
unpopular
they've been mass demonstrations even a
nationwide strike
people haven't been able to buy the
basics
[Music]
so it's tough to label tunisia a success
but it's also hard to ignore that it's
done better than the others
ten years is not a long time to
transform a country
let alone a whole region and in the last
couple of years there have been more
protests
in places like sudan algeria and lebanon
the fear barrier
that was broken 10 years ago has
emboldened so many
to continue to call out their
governments the arab spring is in many
ways
not over it's just started tunisia is
far from a perfect example
but people there do have the freedom to
elect who leads them
to demand change to be heard that's what
muhammad was easy wanted
to be heard it's what millions of people
wanted
when they rose up 10 years ago
we have a lot more online that looks
back at the arab spring
you'll find all sorts of analysis and
interactives on aljazeera.com
i'll see you next week for another
episode of start here